so as a side note if you think that
government is the best way to help
people that are hurting versus giving to
your local ministry or charity that does
the same kind of thing or giving to the
individuals that are hurting directly
you can pay extra taxes if you send in
more than you owe they'll keep it so if
you really believe that higher taxes are
the best way to help people send in more
of your money put your money where your
mouth is if you don't really believe
that then it's unfair for you to ask for
anyone to pay higher taxes you ought to
ask for anyone you ought to be rejoicing
that anyone pays less in taxes even rich
people even evil corporations by the way
it's impossible for a corporation to be
evil it's impossible corporations don't
have a soul corporations don't have a
personality the people that work for
them do there sometimes there's some
evil people that work for corporations
and sometimes there's some evil people
that some wonderful people that work for
corporations but corporations aren't by
definition evil or good they can't be
they don't have they're not an entity
that has the ability to be evil or good
so quit making stupid butt statements
about that - it makes you look dumb so
it'd mean so taxing the evil
corporations because you deemed them
evil just makes you look dumb so by the
way if they don't pay if they pay less
in taxes and that money goes anywhere
except the government that's a good
thing less taxes period - anyone
anywhere at anytime is a good thing if
you if you
the premise that government is a bad
methodology for an ineffective
inefficient methodology for actually
doing anything it does then lowering
taxes and doing less of all the stuff it
does poorly would be a good thing that's
the premise that's a logical outflowing
of understanding basic common sense and
that's not a GOP thing that's not a
conservative thing it's not a liberal
thing it's not a Democrat thing so just
idea that maybe they take less of your
money or maybe just your neighbors money
maybe you remember your taxes stay the
same and they take less of your
neighbors money just rejoice in that
that they have less money up there that
you should always rejoice that any time
they get less money just think about it
that way and it helps you kind of get
past all of the emotional crap that some
of your political friends tell you it's
not a politics thing it's a math thing
when something is done poorly don't give
people more listen if your
brother-in-law spends every dime he
makes and he wants money from you don't
give him money cuz he spends every time
he makes well that's what the government
is it's your stupid brother-in-law with
lots of zeros don't give it more money
and don't ask anybody else to give it
more money this is dumb it's straight-up
DOM and so people ask on time dude what
do you think about the tech school what
do you think about the text changes
honestly I haven't read through the
details because I don't give a rip I
read through the details because I
really do not care what they're trying
to do other than if it's lower it's
better for anybody if I don't get a tax
break and you do good I'm glad they
lowered it maybe I'll get the next one
just don't raise mine so you can lower
yours oh that's ridiculous hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
now
[Applause]
[Music]